monsieur penderie vous étiez engagé à
protéger notre emploi pas un non pas
deux ans pas trois ans pas quatre ans au
moins cinq ans est-ce que vous tenez
votre parole oui le groupe il a tenu ses
promesses on demande à votre pitié on
demande juste que vous respectez votre
parole où vous tenez votre parole et on
reprend le travail où vous ne tenez pas
l'accord que vous avez passé et on
continue à bloquer la production du le
stock mais je sans appel la justice
aujourd'hui est là pour dire non à la
fermeture de nos dans la constitution
est inscrit la liberté d'entreprendre la
liberté d'entreprendre veut dire qu'un
patron peut ouvrir et fermer une
entreprise non drummondville a fait 17
millions d'euros de bénéfices ça veut
dire quand on a un pdg qui a dit un
ministre
allez vous faire [ __ ] de jeu parce que
je veux ça les jeunes assez on ne refait
jamais gagné assez d'argent
qu'est-ce qu'on devient dans cette
histoire qu'est ce que deviennent les
salariés ont sa place en dehors et les
familles entières des enfants des pères
des mères
je me bats pour un chef un chèque qu'on
va toucher à la fin de chaque mois
c'est pour ça qu'on va se battre tous
ensemble
on a pleuré la perte je me demande de
partir s'est il également tandis que je
vous dis on ne bougera pas
[Applaudissements]
s'il n'y a pas de rencontre un débouché
qui reprend dialogue
ça va vraiment dégénéré
[Applaudissements]